hi guys I'm Alvin vinca and we love food
we do love food especially street food I
think it's safe to say that when we
travel it's for food our stomachs always
tell us where we should go next so where
are we going today we are going to be
trying some awesome egg waffle which is
from Hong Kong there's a place in
Chinatown
that makes egg waffles they're gonna
kind of show us how they do it and then
we're gonna try and bring this back to
the office and try to make it in the
tasty kitchen so then you guys can also
have it at home hungry super hungry
let's go
oh are you why you running hi Michael
hey tell us a little bit more about we
actually start the store 3 years ago
it's kind of influence from the great
street food culture that we have in Hong
Kong it was like a big part of my
childhood and I decided I wanted to turn
that into business alright when we have
here so we have our core ingredients for
making a waffle so our eggs of course
trimix
white ingredients and butter and what is
this this is our egg waffle pad I want
to show this because this is like your
secret mix yeah Michael won't tell us
what's actually in it so like I quit and
then I pour my sugar in whisk it it's
really pretty much almost like making a
normal walk yeah almost exact same but
we use a lot more hey give it that
flavor the like nice custardy taste to
it so we mix it - it's like a pretty
incorporated consistency milk Lebanon
Ella extract dry ingredients
[Music]
so I pour my butter in so we actually
let rest for overnight it helps it rise
a little bit
baking powder oh oh yeah what's that
so he's our batter that we had set
overnight it's a lot thicker and
smoother golden that's what our batter I
know I'm trying to memorize this color
right now you ready for this egg waffle
I'm so ready
you know when they make it on the
streets they go like turn turn yeah yeah
turn turn
feel like I'm shooting image tiles sorry
I miss some room for this shot Wow
swivel around swivel it around on the
bottom it gets like the boys yeah just
look it's like the right eggy shape to
it turn set the timer and now we wait
oh it comes in the timer yeah it smells
so good where did you get this machine
um you get import from China it's like I
hope amazon has there's like a story
about how chefs used to have like these
throwaway it's like they're broken eggs
and they you still wanted to make
indicates instead of going it away oh
it's ready I'll be very gentle I will be
gentle
wow this looks so legit what do you
think makes you really good egg waffle
well great egg waffles usually really
crunchy on the outside and then it's
like airy and gooey on the inside can we
eat this yeah all right I'm just gonna
do this how's it and it's like not a
really sweet it's chewy on the inside
crispy on the outside this was so good I
love it like just the traditional style
but I also know you do some really cool
stuff here can we try it I mean we have
a bunch of different really cool options
and we're all about picking whatever you
want the egg waffle blow it up blow it
up can we eat it before the ice cream
melts yeah all right well Michael thank
you that was amazing thank you for
showing us both the traditional egg
waffle as well as modern egg blue I
think we our work cut out for us Michael
thank you all right so we are back here
in the tasty kitchen and we have been
testing a lot of recipes systems are
back here I think that we have found the
one
so first up before anything else we want
to kind of combine all our dry
ingredients and we want to sift that
just to make sure there's no lumps all
right
I'll be sifting duty sifting it when we
do poor yes please
I'm 1 sifting duty under flour we have
the tapioca starch this is basically
what kind of helps make it more chewy
making powder this is just to help it
arrives a little bit last thing in terms
of dry ingredients is this custard
powder this is actually using a lot of
like Hong Kong I think baking goods like
egg tarts oh sorry safety duty we had
one job and we're just gonna give these
dry ingredients a nice old mix and then
this is pretty much done you don't
actually have to mix it for that long
and we're gonna bring in the wet
ingredients so let's go get some eggs
okay hold on
so we have our wet ingredients and we
have a double boiler setup pot of water
going underneath and a clear last pole
on top all right I will name my egg Jim
oh you named your head good haha bye Jim
okay that's one all right we're gonna
give these eggs a twist we're not trying
to cook the eggs here but I think that
he kind of just helps become a little
more fluffy when the yolks and the white
are together as one as one as one that
was poetic
hahaha we can add in the sugar slowly
but surely and then the he kind of helps
the sugar dissolve you whisk together
eggs and sugar together and you go kind
of fast
look at you putting that elevation on
that it kind of makes the eggs a little
bit fluffier then you end up with like
nice ribbons which is kind of cool so
I'll go for another minute
what's that are you putting a spell on
that I think I can take over for the
people who are wondering is this five
minutes really necessary our culinary
team did try one without you know
beating it like this but what happens it
was not as fluffy and we want to give
you guys a recipe that's like legit so
it sounds like a lot of work but it's
gonna be worth it in bed okay but as you
can see it's getting lighter and paler
in color it's getting a little more
fluffy how's your arm it's a bit tired
look at that
it's like ribbons there's no ribbon you
made that huh
Jim and good otama have become great
friends and we're gonna keep going
so next up we do what I have to do when
I work with Alvin who next up we have
some evaporated milk and some water so
we're just gonna go right in here with
the milk peaceful you know tasty
producer right here but you want to be
careful right cuz there's a lot of
bubbles right now we're gonna combine
these two now they're just the dry
ingredients from earlier so I'm just
gonna gently do this
oh it's getting thicker now getting
thicker Anka has a more gentle touch
she's gonna take over right now but
basically if you beat it too much the
gluten in the flour starts to really get
worked up and getting tight and we don't
want that we have vegetable oil and some
vanilla oh yeah I stopped mixing because
I think it's pretty much done super
important next step you want to run this
through this again especially when it's
Alvin who's sifting the ingredients you
know you just want to make sure
let's go Alvin so all right ready to fix
my problem all right so on top is your
layer of mistakes and on the bottom is a
filtered out perfection so now it's
really important that you arrest your
batter reason we need to do that is
because you want it to retain that
fluffy texture and if you don't do that
you're just gonna get some like harder
waffles
we just need plastic wrap on it chief
help
what are you ready go to sleep two three
all right good night sleep well we'll
see you in a bit
all right so our batter is resting and
you're probably wondering what is this
big machine this is actually the
traditional og egg waffle machines
probably the ones that we see actually
on the streets I saw this growing up in
Hong Kong you open it it's got these
like long handles it was the closest we
could get at least to like the actual
thing but it was very expensive so there
is an alternative if you do not want
this machine you can get this one this
is sort of like a regular waffle iron
cost around thirty five has the same
amount of holes it looks super similar
so we're gonna show you what each of
these machines does to their waffles and
oh that's not it
so this has been arrested overnight I
want to show you guys look look at this
this is that ribbony texture we were
talking about it is so beautiful we look
will you do the honors of turning Bob on
you don't have to name a big no-no
so we've turned it up to 200 degrees
Celsius get lit it's around the 400 425
fahrenheit range I think the beauty of a
really nice egg waffle is that it's
smooth it's one piece this is why ovens
really taking a lot of time here just
slowly dab away every little hole needs
to be filled
that's where did your brain go my brain
is just like any other brain so it is
getting pretty steamy in here this is
one you know it's ready I'm gonna fill
this up to around 80% give it a little
twirl and then I'll pick it up from
there or Elvin will take it away all
right here we go
it's a superintendent okay times ticking
let's go what's happening so I'm just
doing a little thing to cover all the
areas I'm gonna seal it you can imagine
the batter going left and right and
filling all those holes I'm just gonna
turn it upside down the challenge is if
you don't do it fast enough it all cooks
two half minutes on the clock yeah I did
good if I didn't know who you were I
would buy one from Elvin police tell us
about this cool setup because in Hong
Kong let me buy this from the sheet
vendors they have it beautiful like you
shape but Alvin came up with a solution
if you take two bowls and you put a
round wooden rolling pin and you arrest
the waffle that's hot like this it will
naturally fall and it'll be great she
said I was genius I am going to get
wooden spoon or chopstick times ticking
we got one minute left good Wow and I
think because you really oily this real
well it came right off you ever go an
ice cream shop and they're making fresh
waffle cones do an invert it it's hot as
a lot of sugar but they get hard over
time so you need a set why are you
dancing all right so it's hot you gotta
cool it you got to make sure it molds
together so you put it on this thing and
once it cools down it will become a nice
cone tacos new shape crispy delicious
egg waffle in in normal human words once
it cools down it will Harden how about
you try to make one this time Elvin and
just see if we get that beautiful my
turn left like this whole body movement
you don't have to do that you can just
do it with your wrist two and a half
minutes already Wow got you a cooling
rack tell me a story about your memory
egg waffles were kind of like our treats
you know it's like it was cheap it was
on the go smell of it reminds me of that
time so it's a very nostalgic smell
are you nervous slightly it kind of want
oh there it is oh all right let us take
this out I got it it's okay little butts
look at this we made a couple more I
think we're ready to open shop yeah what
are we gonna name the shop
Aggies friends all right we're gonna
come back to that we're gonna do one
more egg waffle on that other machine we
were talking about it's right here we
want to make sure that this can also
turn into this just like before we're
gonna oil it as well close so this one
the movement is a little janky so it's a
little more playful oh that's it let's
just say it looks a little different
than the one we made here if you look at
it it's super similar Wow
I'm so happy so as you can see you too
can achieve in great big waffle
we're gonna do a little taste test and
it's still crispy Oh
oh my god childhood you can see that
these little bits
they're super crunchy and crispy one
side is clearly more Hollow and the
other side is more cakey
this is what you want right because when
you do the twirl thingy you get the
chewiness from the denser side where you
get the light puffiness from the side
that's a little more open this is how
it's normally served Elvin somehow found
these brown paper bags but now the real
test is can we sell them and this
version live up to this version all
right here we go it still got pockets of
air in it there's still some little
hollow pockets it's not as much as the
other one
Cheers mmm still crunchy hmm but it's a
little darker this little shinier mmm I
think that's because the high heat and
the other pan almost caramelizes some of
the sugar more honestly if you gave me
both I would buy both I never thought I
would be able to eat something so local
to Hong Kong's culture here we're gonna
have the recipe fooling this Griffin
block if you guys have any other sheet
for suggestions that you think we should
be doing let us know in the comments and
see you guys next time really gonna take
all those bye oven Inca please a Capri
[Music]
you